vous vous sentez les spectacles au final
je suis encore sur un nuage
pas dans ce sens que j'ai jamais cru de
toute ma vie j'avais ici puis plus quand
les rêves se réalisent et aussi quand
les rêves se réalisent d'une bonne façon
puis dans un bon temps dans sa carrière
pour les bonnes raisons aussi j'étais
ici avec une création qu'on a fait à
toronto quand même jetés ici je me
sentais quand même le représentant du
canada dans ce sens que c'est une
création qui s'est passé à toronto
instant un rôle que j'ai dansé beaucoup
alors c'est un rôle que j'étais très
confortable puis aussi benjamen
députe-maire partenaires du monde des
grandes ballerines de russie vous
expliquer aux gens qu'ils connaissent
pas nécessairement ballet l'importance
d'être parce que c'est un rôle que vous
connaissez vous avez des conceptualiser
de le faire sur le bord de la peur au
bolchoï en russie qu'est ce que ça
change à l'énergie sur scène
l'info c'est ici que la danse et décret
c'est ainsi que l'histoire de la danse
est tellement forte au site
une compagnie de 290 danseurs certains
himer danseurs du monde et pas juste en
deux mais des dizaines et des dizaines
fait que faut vraiment avoir quelque
chose de spécial je pense pour avoir une
invitation d'une place comme le bolchoï
pour soit prise au doute l'un des
meilleurs du monde avec mais c'était
vraiment c'était le chorégraphe de la
production qui était vraiment insistant
au 6 mai mais aussi à cause du directeur
ici que je connais de puis il ya dix ans
je pense qu'il n'avait vu danser le rôle
à londres alors il voulait il voulait
trouver une façon de m'amener ici
embauchant et puis ça a comme a donné un
petit peu dernière minute
ouais qu'il y avait quelqu'un qui s'est
retiré d'un spectacle alors j'ai pu
venir d'autres moments préférés de la
soirée est ce que c'est quand le rideau
s'ouvre et se referme sur le balcon dans
le coni c'est quand on a dansé ensemble
si un départ de les plus difficiles du
répertoire surtout cette version-là
d'alexeï ratmansky un des plus éteint
c'est tellement intense est tellement
difficile et ça s'est très bien passé
c'était quelque chose de vraiment
mémorable ce soir dans notre façon de
faire ensemble
je ensemble c'était spontané mais
c'était aussi différent parce qu'on est
comme une diversion différente un peu
fait qu en trois jours on a le temps de
se parler on attend s'adapter mais veut
veut pas il ya de la réalité commencé
pour les créer une complicité avec une
des plus grandes ballerines de russie
mais en trois jours ça c'est des choses
qu'on on peut pas travailler ça dans ce
sens que oui où ça marche ou ça marche
pas et j'étais tellement heureux de
savoir que des deux premiers jours
j'étais super nerveux parce que des fois
tu peux arriver puis sa clique pas du
tout il faut que tu fasses quand même
mais avec elle c'était de la machine dès
le début je pense que même les
répétiteurs et tout le monde a vu qu'il
y avait comme des flammèches quand on
danse a fait et on l'a senti j'espère
parce qu'on voyait vraiment que moi dans
sa salle
je vois que quand je danse avec
quelqu'un qui m'inspire ça me donne
encore plus d'énergie ça me donne un
souffle au lieu de me fatiguer
c'est votre deuxième séjour en russie en
trois mois vous avez été la critique a
été unanime lors de votre passage à
moscou pour initier les moscovites à la
danse moderne le vous êtes au bolchoï
vous avez joué romeo c'est la
consécration qu'est ce qui vient après
sa part du bois je sais pas tout ce que
j'espère c'est de retourner maintenant
ma famille et avoir un beau petit noël
mais c'est quand j'ai commencé à arrêter
de deux arrêter de chercher des choses
trop loin que les portes se sont
ouvertes plus facilement dans ce sens
que tout ce que je fais c'est ce que je
pense que on doit dire surtout à nos
jeunes parce que maintenant avec des
enfants c'est que plus on travaille
chaque jour sur ce qu'on veut faire plus
d opportunités vont souvent ce saumon
s'ouvrir devant nous au lieu d'essayer
de chercher les opportunités avec moi
j'ai toujours travaillé plus fort
possible
je travaille à toronto on est de retour
quant à toronto fake dernière soirée à
moscou on fait quoi après le spectacle
de danse comme ça se couche et s'imagine
moi je sors ce soir parce que ce que je
vais aller dans le discours puis je vais
aller prendre une série où quelque chose
quelque chose de drôle parce que je
pense j'ai besoin d'une célébration pour
voir ça merci beaucoup merci